[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one
you were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus
ready captain let you ready as i'll ever
be commander hawthorne this is exciting
a new adventure i'm gonna grant you four
minutes to be off planet but then you
come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyper launch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear star command coming star
command
why don't they answer look hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone yum yum yum
yum yum
years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
you know what i'm saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 hmm seems a
bit low mission failure imminent in
three grandma always said she believed
in you too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a better don't at least record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle
if if you're satisfied with this
recording speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
bye